[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so as me walking down the corridor and
I'm greeted by this amazing healthy
which is Professor Matt Collins well off
this if I have to know the National
traditional business diagram it's the
best self care by the team I think you
know that feeling where you see
something that is so good that you
wonder why you even bother trying to do
it yourself that's very much the feeling
I just got watching Bill works if
history of the world like if you haven't
seen it oh my god it's amazing there's
no point in me doing this anymore so
this is another green section of campus
that you haven't seen before at
lunchtime I am going off to the gym I've
actually gone to the gym and lifted
weights quite a few times and while
still in the vlog I've just not captured
it up until now so actually has some
pretty amazing sports 230 they spent
like ten million pounds on the gym was
I'm craving and you've already seen bits
of it like that's the tennis courts that
down and I played in before they've got
kind of facility to basically every
sport that's played in the UK it's kind
of anything actually that's Ryan going
there the wait cave
[Music]
man look at all these people who have
got exams all that used to be me I
haven't taken it like a proper paper
exam since 2012
was it 2013 2013 I just have one massive
scary one at the end of the PhD instead
but you can blog through that you can't
exactly blog on a paper exam about
physics
I much prefer my way now with the
workout done I've got to get some of
that sweet sweet fuel
No
so let's say you're in the water and you
have a cube and you know the direction
and speed that the water's moving in
then you can ask yourself a question how
much water is in this cube and is that
amount of water changing so the amount
of water in the queue is pretty easy to
work out you just multiply the width the
height and the depth by the density of
water which we represent by the Greek
letter Rho and I can tell you that the
matter where these air is pointing and
they can be pointing in all different
directions the all different sizes for
water as we physically know it the
amount of water in that cube is one of
the keep stays the same size isn't going
to change and that's because water is an
incompressible fluid if you push down on
water the density of it isn't going to
change actually it does slightly the
very bottom of the ocean but try and
center purposes it's a constant density
throughout so Rho is the same wherever
you're looking and furthermore the flow
the way how the water is moving is what
we call non divergent water isn't just
being like appearing or in Minecraft or
something at a point where water is to
spontaneously spouting out or equally a
point where water is just vanishing and
you know when we think about the
bouncing like going down a drain the
water isn't vanishing it's just moving
from where you're holding it to
somewhere else the water itself isn't
ever destroyed or created if we weren't
under water and these air is now
represented where air was moving instead
of where the water is moving then we
have more interesting problem because a
density of air can vary in both time and
space in other words the air here is at
a different density than the air in the
stratosphere
you know 20,000 meters up so depending
on the flow the amount of air by the
amount of air I mean the mass of air in
the cube could change over time this can
be written in what's known as the
continuity equation which look like this
such that the rate of change of density
equals the negative divergence of the
momentum field so in other words the
momentum of anything is at the mass
times velocity this is the density times
the velocity field so those arrows
before and this is the idea of something
springing out nothing or disappearance
and the divergence so when we said that
it was a divergence free flow on Monday
version flow it means this is zero
zoom in for dramatic effect now this is
one of the most fundamental equations in
fluid dynamics and it is a new way that
it is wrong it's absolutely right
and what I've been doing over the past
couple of months I guess was just
basically double checking this equation
applied over an average that we were
considering because we are considering
the pressure averaged over the whole
North Pole errors 65 degrees north to
the pole and that's where I was tasked
by myself with checking this equation
held when you're considering the density
of air in that area and the flow the
boundaries so in other words be follow
the north-south velocity into or out of
the area this had to add up and up until
today it really didn't now the reason it
didn't work was because of a subtlety
but completely passed me by so something
like I mentioned before is the climate
data supplied on precious services so
say you're interested in how temperature
changes as you go up and then you know
that the temperature will decrease up to
a point where you hit the the tropopause
and then it will stay the same
approximately now the way that you can
do that is you could say at one
kilometer up it's this value it could be
I don't know like 260 Kelvin or
something like that and then a 2
kilometers up and so on and so forth is
such that you're measuring on a regular
grid like 1 o'clock to 2 o'clock search
through kilometers above the surface but
this often isn't done because the
equations that we use in the atmosphere
are easier to work with if they're on
what will they call isip is that in
isobaric form which means that you're
holding pressure is constant what that
means is that instead of the vertical
axis being height it's pressure so you
say that a thousand hectare Pascal's
which is roughly sea level the
temperature is say 270 Kelvin or minus
three so there are Celsius and then you
decrease the pressure let's say that 300
hetz Pascal's that
which era is 214 Kelvin I'm making this
up the point is that you're saying apps
instead of saying at this height the
temperature equals this you're saying
that at this pressure the temperature
equals this now if you wanted to go back
to considering the temperature as a
function of height you need to know the
height of these pressure services so
we're above the ground is the equal of
thousand x Pascal's and you can do that
through a variable called the G
potential so you can get datasets where
it says 4,000 hectopascal pressure
surface at this part on the globe at
like unknown second of January at 60
degrees north and 20 degrees west
it has a G potential of this and that
varies all around the earth it varies in
time and you can get the height of the
pressure surface from that just by
dividing geopotential by G the
gravitational constant this is where the
subtlety comes in and also why I've
drawn land under here because I thought
my entire academic career the
geopotential was measured relative to
the graph at the ground so if you had a
mountain it meant that the geopotential
was measured relative to that so that
like the jib tension equals 0 surface is
the ground but it's not it turns out it
has that it's actually measured relative
to sea level so if they're land in the
way it means that the geopotential of
the land surface is greater than 0 and
of course if you're over the sea then
the jib potential equals 0 surface is
sea level it's the ground so the code
that I was writing to check the
continuity equation was effectively I'm
changing from pressure coordinates back
to high coordinates by by doing this and
considering the pressure surfaces and
height they're at and then do some funky
mess but it wasn't working out for some
reason the the prediction of how much
air was in our cube which was over the
North Pole was changing over time in a
way that didn't match up with what you'd
expect from the air that flowed in and
out of it and it turned out it was
because I was interpolating I was
basically doing this this conversion
from brush to high coordinate assuming
that this
with zero on the ground rather than a
sea level and it meant that the
difference look like a seasonal cycle
so now that I've coded in that this
correction and changing it so that I
don't use surface pressure at the bottom
of my my cert by pressure dataset and
I'm not using sea level pressure
suddenly it works and it's the most
minor of things that completely stumped
me for quite a few weeks so there's a
lesson here to all PhD people and you
know specifically in strict climate I
guess
look at what your variables mean and
where they're measured relative to
because it does make a big difference
but you learn by mistakes so you know
I'm better off for knowing it and a few
weeks further down the line now that
I've implemented that I'm left it
running overnight to do like a long run
because I checked a little tiny part of
the data set and I want to be able to
check at least several years worth so
stacked me to go home so Dan's having
some people over later which means he
has been engaging in literally his
favorite activity in the world which is
cleaning and my god
the house is absolutely spotless
you're pretty good housewife me right
off the chapel quite done refuses to do
that that son
that's definitely something do you have
a message for your adoring fans here
they cool
don't be like huger we do actually
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]